EUGENE OKSMAN: My name is
Eugene, and this is Akhilesh.
And together we run the
mobile SDK for Salesforce.
Our mission is pretty simple--
to help developers create
amazing mobile apps that are
powered by the enterprise data.
So when it comes
to creating apps
that you use at your job, your
employee-facing applications,
Salesforce is a
great platform that
allows you to consume
your enterprise data
and put that inside
any mobile experience.
Obviously no mobile
conversation is
complete without getting into
the debate between native
and HTML5.
You've all been there.
Our position is pretty
straightforward.
It depends on you.
You make the decision
on an app by app basis.
That's why when we talk about
our mobile SDK, we layer it.
And we provide you with all
the essential functionality
that you need to create a really
solid enterprise mobile app.
So we start by
providing identity
via the OAuth2 standard.
We have a secure
offline database in case
your app needs to work when
it's completely disconnected.
We have API wrappers and data
synchronization techniques
so that you can easily move
objects and data back and forth
between the cloud and
your mobile applications.
But when it comes to
creating the user interface,
we give you the
choice-- especially when
it comes to creating
HTML-based apps.
There are a lot of great
frameworks out there.
All of them have their merits,
and it's really up to you
how you leverage them.
So now by combining your
HTML with a hybrid container
that we have based on
PhoneGap, web developers
become mobile developers.
And ultimately, we believe
that is the future,
enabling every web developer
to become a mobile developer.
But I'm here to talk about
our journey with Polymer.
About a year ago, I
was on Hacker News,
like I start my daily
morning, and I saw this link
to this brand new framework.
I was like, all right.
I'll go check it out.
I started watching the video
with Matt from Google I/O,
and I was just
completely blown away.
This is from last year.
So in my excited state,
I ran over to Akhilesh
and started ranting.
It's like, come on!
We have to try this framework.
It's amazing.
It's easy.
It's powerful.
Look at Designer.
Look at Sandbox.
It's so cool.
He was like, yeah, whatever.
You talk to me in [? bren. ?]
You framework every single day.
But as we started
this conversation,
we realized that
Polymer was unique.
It was based on polyfills.
A lot of the platform
stuff was going
to go away and be
baked into the browser.
And that was a really
attractive to us.
That's why we released our
first version of our components
based on Polymer at
our annual conference.
And we demoed that on stage
in front of a large audience.
So now I'll go into Sandbox and
show you what we demonstrated.
So what I have here is
an instance of Sandbox
that we wired up with several
Salesforce components.
So I'll start by dragging
over the visual components
for the navigation.
Pretty simple components
of starting up.
And then I'll drag over a list.
And the idea here
is that we want
to build a product catalog
for L'Oreal, a branded product
catalog that they could
submit to their employees
and into their apps.
So now that I've dragged
this UI list element,
you just saw a lot of data.
Well, this component
behind the scenes,
made according to our cloud,
it got all of the information,
with the proper
security permissions,
and rendered this list.
Pretty cool.
It was that simple.
And if you look at the
code, all it is right
now is just three lines.
But now I want to
transform this list.
I'm pointing to one of
our accounts tables,
but I'm building
a product catalog.
So I'll change this to
point to the product table.
And just like that,
everything changed.
New REST API call, new data.
I can then further decorate
this particular table
by changing some of
the exposed attributes.
Let's add a picture.
And just like that, new
data has been sent back
to this visual element.
No change in code, just
changing the parameters.
And the behaviors and this list
automatically reflect that.
But this app was
supposed to be branded.
It was supposed
to be for L'Oreal.
Now Akhilesh and I are
not web developers,
so we decided to leverage
the power of the web
by going to L'Oreal's website
and taking their stylesheets.
So we literally went
to this website,
copied some of the
style properties,
put them into our app.
And now when we change the
stylesheets to that of L'Oreal,
immediately the look
and feel changes
of this particular component.
And it's that simple.
It's the same 20 lines of code.
And it looks like
magic, but it's really
the power of web components,
all the complexities hidden.
And as a developer, this
is all you have to use.
So this was our first
release, and we've
learned a great
deal about Polymer.
And I'll hand it
over to Akhilesh
to talk about what
we built next.
AKHILESH GUPTA: Thanks
so much, Eugene.
So as Eugene sort of
showed us the journey,
all we started with
simple elements.
Actually, we have come
quite a long way now.
We have kind of built up
our own sort of gallery
of our own elements here.
And initially when
we started, we really
did not have much of an element.
We started with some
basic data elements.
And you can see in this
category, and lot of people
sort of talked about
this beforehand,
you need to think about elements
in two different categories.
The ones which are
just data elements,
or non-visual elements, they
just do behind the scenes
all the work for you and
help other visual elements
to really render properly.
So we have few data elements,
such as S Object collection
here to sort of point to
some tables inside Salesforce
and gather some list of
records from Salesforce
and the detail to fetch any
record detail from Salesforce.
But then we started to
work on some UI elements,
and we had some the simplest
in view elements initially,
just to show simple application.
But then we actually
started to work around
with the rest of our
colleagues, and we
realized that our
user experience
team had been working
on a prototyping
framework with Angular.
And they were building a
bunch of different components
in Angular, like web
directives almost,
to help build a design
framework so that they
can test new designs and do
some user research with them.
So we talked to them.
We told them about Polymer,
and they were super excited
about that.
And within actually
few hours, they
were able to turn their
Angular components
into Polymer components.
And you can see
the gallery here--
and this is all hosted
on a Heroku website--
you can see there is a whole
gallery of more than 100+
components.
And you can see if I drag
and drop, like for example
this element.
It's a simple
anchor doc element,
we call it, and exposes all the
properties on the right side.
Through our designer tool, I
can go change anything here.
I can put my name.
And that's the
beauty of Polymer.
I change any attribute
that start to show up.
So all these elements which
were, like whatever, Angular
earlier, were now Polymer with
live binding capabilities.
We have a calendar component.
We have a navigation component
I can pull down here.
So if you're building
an application,
you want to have some navigation
on the left side-- we all
are used to that
through Facebook
and other applications.
A notification section.
So we have your built, building
these sort of core elements
for prototyping.
But now when we could
attach them with real data,
they really can
come alive and may
help you build a proper
application, which is exactly
which I kind of want
to show you here.
So what we can do
here, for example,
I can pull a simple
list element,
which is nothing
but a static HTML.
It's creating simple list
of [? ULL and LIs. ?]
And what I can do is I can
bind with real data coming
from Salesforce.
But to do that, I'll first just
log into Salesforce account.
It will ensure that
OAuth flow and give me
a session from Salesforce.
And I can drag and drop
this invisible element
behind the scenes
which is just running
a query against
our account table.
And I can bind these
two together now,
just by simply selecting
my collection object
and using the
collection property.
And while it quickly just
pulls all my account records,
sales account records
from Salesforce,
or the box using other
APIs, I can go back
to my collection element,
change anything here.
If I want to look at,
say, Contact Table,
look at the recent
items from there.
I can just change
some properties,
and now I have a
list of contacts
coming from Salesforce.
So let me show you
some more stuff.
I can put some list
header in there
to make it more contextual.
I can go to my list
header element.
Drag it up there on the top.
Give it more context.
Bind back to my data element.
And specify the object on
our table am I looking at.
Give some visual
indication of the icon.
So now it shows exactly
which kind of information I'm
looking at.
But this is, again,
the simple view.
When we look at
these demos, we're
always concerned about, OK.
Can I really build an
application with this?
So what I was doing
was we actually
built up a scaffold
element, which
basically nothing but a
container in some ways,
where you can put
a navigation area.
So I can drag and drop my
navigation element here,
which I showed you guys
a little bit earlier.
So I can just drag
and drop it here.
So I have now
navigation working.
I have a notifications area.
I can drag and drop
notifications here.
And then I was centrally
sort of manager of it,
I can build my application.
And I can put these elements
now back into this guy,
and bind this whole
application from my navigation
on the left side.
So what I could do is go
back to my collection object.
Instead pointing
at the start value,
I can select it
from a navigation
and say, selected
as object property.
And voila! it automatically
pulls in accounts.
So now if I tap
on opportunities,
it's pulling my
opportunities list.
And so I was able to
build that quickly.
And it's kind of a
cooking show that I'm
showing you now
the final product.
So like this is the
full application.
But I can select any object--
and it's kind of the designer
is a little broken here.
But ultimately, it gives
me the simple [INAUDIBLE],
which is just 20 lines
of simple HTML tags
which anyone can understand.
And the power which comes with
Polymer and Mobile SDK, which
we as a product
are working on, I
could just copy/paste
the simple HTML.
Go back to Xcode where I
can create a new project
with Mobile SDK, which works
across on iOS platform.
It's a simple HTML page.
I can just drop this HTML here.
Save this guy, and run
this in my iOS simulator.
It will launch this application.
Authenticate against Salesforce,
using my Salesforce login flow.
And I have now the
same application
running as a native application.
I can just choose any object,
look at the details right here.
I have notifications.
It's a fully-fledged
working application
that I could build in
just 20 lines of code.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Say that
link is available?
EUGENE OKSMAN: So yeah.
So this is part of
our announcement.
Yeah.
So here's the link.
You go to bitly/mobilepacks.
We're an open company, and
so we encourage everybody
to start playing with
these frameworks.
All of the source is
available on GitHub,
and we're putting Designer Host
on Heroku onto this website.
So if you want to build
an enterprise app,
get a free developer account
and start using Polymer.
And together we're going
to change the world.
[APPLAUSE]